she's very much like a housewife in that
she can't stop talking about the very
thing that she wants to be irrelevant
she wants to sort of like eradicate and
erase the royal family
bethany frankel slamming meghan markle
for acting more housewife than hrh
so you want to be a voice for change
a woman for female empowerment so do
that so do that in the future why do we
keep in these nuanced subtle ways keep
referencing
things that happened in the past it all
goes down on the latest episode of just
be with bethany frankel
the entrepreneur calls megan out for
continuing to rehash her experience in
the royal family after stepping down as
a senior member in 2020
i think it's the case that megan
certainly feels that she was um
silenced to a degree she has spoken
about
being able to use her voice now which i
think suggests that as a member as a
working member of the royal family and
she felt at times restricted
it's a topic meg discussed on the
premiere of her new podcast archetypes
i don't
ever remember
personally feeling the negative
connotation behind the word ambitious
until i started dating my now husband
and
[Music]
apparently ambition is a
terrible terrible thing
and again on the second episode
if there's any time in my life that it's
been more focused on my race it's only
once i started dating my husband then i
started to understand what it was like
to be treated like a black woman because
up until then i had been treated like a
mixed woman
bethany's big issue she thinks it's in
the way megan speaks
i think people don't like meghan markle
because i think she talks down to other
people i think she's sanctimonious and i
think there's this subtext of elevation
she's up there we're down here and
bethany says megan's platform is kind of
hypocritical i want to separate myself
from the royal family i was treated
horribly subtle i'm gonna do these and
these hidden messages this morse code to
the public that's not gonna directly say
what i'm saying but everybody in the
royal family and in great britain
understands exactly what i'm saying so
like like at least say rip the band-aid
off say they're a bunch of
they're uptight white
racist white supremacist
come out say it or don't but like these
nuanced i want my privacy but i want a a
a podcast i want my privacy but i want a
netflix special b's advice she thinks
megan should take a cue from another
famous princess
let it go
let it go
let it go elsa move forward
create change in the future and leave
that family behind because it's only
creating more drama for your husband
but bethany's opinion on megan is really
nothing new
back in 2021 after megan and harry's
bombshell interview with oprah winfrey
the former real housewives star didn't
have much sympathy for meg's experience
tweeting crimea river the plight of
being a game show host fairly unknown
actress to suffering in a palace with
tiaras and seven-figure weddings for two
whole years to being a household name
with oprah on speed dial fetching 7
million for interviews and hundreds of
millions in media deals alongside a
thinking face emoji we saw what happened
like we watched the tell-all
it's not like a shock that we're reading
now that the there was a chilly
reception they weren't standing on the
main balcony they weren't sitting in the
front row no
sherlock but you
aired your dirty laundry of the most
public family on the planet earth
megan has yet to respond to bethany's
comments but one thing we do know the
royals feel disappointed by meg's
continued confessions
a source telling e.t quote they are
distressed that after stepping back from
the royal family claiming a need for
privacy she continues to publicize
family matters in public
[Music]